a growing number of countries are
banning travel from the united kingdom
to block a new strain of coronavirus
that is sweeping across southern england
now the measures are already causing
havoc at airports and other travel hubs
in the uk which is now
effectively cut off from continental
europe
now the governments of ireland france
belgium the netherlands
also denmark germany and poland also on
this list
austria italy and also bulgaria all
these countries are barring entry for
people who are traveling
from britain more are expected to follow
suit
the new coronavirus mutation is believed
to spread more quickly
forcing the british government to impose
a strict lockdown on the capital london
and nearby areas
some of the last uk passengers to arrive
in the netherlands this year
they arrived in the country just hours
after it was announced that all travel
from the uk to the netherlands will be
banned for at least
two weeks
these were the final passengers from
london to belgium
who also shut up their borders to uk
travelers
several other countries across the world
followed suit
with many of their nationals having to
change travel plans just before
christmas
coming home for the christmas most
important things being with family so i
think
i just jumped the gun and went to it
that was the idea i paid about 250
pounds for a flight
last night but i was meant to come on
wednesday
yeah home for a good while now so just
being safe from quarantining while here
and then get to see kind of family and
friends the eu are holding crisis talks
in brussels on monday
to decide on a coordinated response to
the new variant
a compulsory negative test may be one of
the prerequisites for travel
whatever the measure will decide on in
48 hours time it's probable the pcr test
will be compulsory
that's why i invite people to go and get
tested because there's a delay before
getting the result
until a solution is reached people and
goods
will remain stuck within the uk's
borders
let's get some perspective on this now
we can speak to john campbell
he's an independent health analyst in
the uk
and he joins us for more hi john good to
have you back on our show
first of all can you explain to us what
is different about this new strain
so this new strain was first identified
in late september
and it appears to have originated in
kent in england although that's not
necessarily the case because in england
we have a very high level of
surveillance
genomics uk has actually sequenced 140
000 viral samples
so it's a bit difficult to say where it
originated but the difference is that
this is a cluster that's characterized
by
17 different mutations within the genome
of the virus and that gives rise to 17
amino acid changes in the proteome of
the virus the overall
structure of the virus and the most
significant of those mutations is called
n501y and this is particularly important
because this is the 501st
amino acid in the spike protein in the
receptor binding domain of the spike
protein
which as you'll know is the bit that
actually latches into the cells
so this has actually changed the
potential infectivity of the virus
and we believe that the infectivity of
the virus has increased
well germany's chief virologist here
today said that he's not yet convinced
that it is that
much more of infectious i mean how
worried are you about this mutation
well we noticed that this mutation was
spreading in london for example it
spread in the last few months from
london from being from being none to
about 25 in november
to being about two-thirds of cases in
london now and throughout the southeast
and it's spreading to other parts of the
united kingdom
so it does appear to be more infectious
in terms of correlation
because the areas where the infection
has been increasing
most dramatically is also the areas
where the highest
incidence of this mutation has been
picked up but as well as that there's
been studies done in the lab
in port and down now this isn't
published in peer-reviewed data yet but
we're getting reports
that this virus is more contagious is
more infectious
and it could be around about 70 percent
more contagious
now that's significant because that
would increase the r value
by 0.4 so it is a potentially
significant increase and it's already
spread throughout other parts of the
united kingdom in as well it's in wales
it's in scotland and people when these
restrictions were announced these t4
tier 4 restrictions were announced in
london people like fled london to all
parts of the country
so there is the potential for spread and
because it's been around since september
there's also potential but it already is
in european countries
it's just that the uk has got a
particularly high level of genomic
surveillance so
maybe it's just that we picked it up
first this is not really clear yet
but i am concerned it's more infectious
that is the concentric consensus of
medical opinion
in the uk at the moment we'll have to
leave it there john campbell independent
health analyst joining us from the uk
thank you so much for that
analysis thank you so much thank you
let's bring in our correspondent spirit
mass in london and max sander
in brussels berget britain has
effectively been blacklisted
travel from the uk to several countries
has been banned
how is britain reacting to that
well boris johnson is holding crisis
talks with his cabinet this morning in
an emergency
meeting and they need to establish how
exactly the
uk is affected there is one concern
which
is food supply because it's not only air
travel it's not only passengers that
can't go
but it's also um lorries that cannot go
to france and we know that there are
already
um huge queues so there's no
um there's no fresh produce for the
moment uh al
also coming in from france so that
obviously if that continues that would
be a concern and so the government will
be addressing that
also what does it mean for medical
supplies for example the coronavirus
vaccine there are
more batches expected here in the uk and
the government needs to solve
how that will come into the country and
it's been reported that military
airplanes are on standby
but yes those are just some of the
issues that
the cabinet will be debating this
morning
max i understand that representatives of
the eu
countries are planning to meet later to
coordinate their response
to the new strain of the virus could we
see even more restrictions imposed
here on the continent perhaps further
border closures
right terry well we have seen some
strong reactions from eu leaders from eu
countries already over the past
24 hours or so and it really does seem
that eu
and eu leaders are in panic mode right
now with
numbers really out of control and uh
this news of this new uh
strain of virus uh coming up now the eu
a council uh presidency
headed by germany has called for this
crisis meeting later today where they
will come together
discuss how to go forward on this
they will try to coordinate response as
closely as possible it's also important
important to point out
that the eu does not have any
competencies
in terms of border management in terms
of when a member state opens or closed
its borders that is
entirely up to the member states but
we've seen in the past
in the beginning of this pandemic back
in march and april
when member states individually started
to close their borders this plunged
a continent in crisis further into
crisis and the eu is quite
keen on not repeating this again but
we'll have to see what comes out of the
meeting for exact measures
berget boris johnson the british prime
minister he has now put
several regions under lockdown uh
and he's done this just days after his
pledge to relax rules over the christmas
period
how's that going down with the british
people
yes the government has announced that
london and
large parts of the south of england are
effectively under lockdown
and this is after boris johnson had four
months really promised that
christmas will be better even at the
beginning of the pandemic he has said
that everything will be normal by
christmas
that's a promise that he can't keep at
all
what's interesting is that he has come
under
a lot of criticism pressure even from
his own back benches he's always
promised this sort of magical moment
uh at christmas that people would be um
that would people could be seeing their
loved ones and now
really at the last minute the government
has canceled that and
the prime minister as recently as last
week the middle of last week he
ridiculed people who were saying
the virus is out of control there needs
to be tougher restrictions
and he was he was ridiculing them for
wanting to cancel christmas and just
two three days later he has to be doing
he has to do exactly that
so a lot of promises when it comes to
coronavirus and christmas that he can't
keep and that's why a lot of british
people are very very
disappointed by this